24 اخبار العالم بجاز من غرف اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم بعد تاكيده مقتل 24
ضابطا وجيا امس في قطاع غزه بينهم 21 في
تفجير مبنيين بمخيم المغازي جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يقول في تحقيق اولي خليه
مسلحين فجرت المبنيين وتمكنت من الانسحاب
وكتائب القسام تصف العمليه شرق مخيم
المغازي بالمركبه وفي الاثناء قال نتنياهو
ان اسرائيل عاشت امس احد اصعب الايام منذ
اندلاع الحرب وتجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب
غزه في رابط بالتعليق الاول لجنه خبراء
التابعه للامم المتحده تقدر ان ما بين 10
الى 15 ال شخص قتلوا منذ نيسان ابريل
الماضي في مدينه الجنينه باقليم دارفور
غربي السودان واتهمت قوات الدعم السريع
وميليشيات عربيه حليفه لها بارتكاب فضائع
يمكن ان ترقى لجرائم ضد الانسانيه طلبات
اللجوء في فرنسا تسجل اعلى مستوى على
الاطلاق خلال العام الماضي وفقا للمكتب
الفرنسي لحمايه اللاجئين وعديم الجنسيه
الذي قال ان عدد الطلبات تجاوز اكثر من
بزياده قدرها
88% هيئه فرنسيه تفرض غرامه قدرها 32
مليون دولار على شركه امازون بسبب
اعتمادها نظاما لمراقبه الموظفين ينطوي
على ما قالت انه تدخل مفرط في نشاطهم وذلك
بعد اربع سنوات من تحقيق خلص الى ان
الشركه وضعت نظاما لمراقبه اداء الموظفين
من خلال مسيحات ضوئيه تسجل اوقات عدم نشاط
الى
اللقاء
ه